[موسيقى
] العالم به مليون ونصف
نوع موصوف عليه ،
نحن نميل إلى إعطاء كل الدعاية
للنمور والغوريلا والباندا العملاقة
ولكن من يهتم بالسمكة
أو العصفور أو الضفدع الذي أفعله ،
اسمي جويل  سارتوري ، أنا
مصور وزميل في المجتمع الجغرافي الوطني
ومؤسس قوس الصورة ، إن
قوس الصورة هو جهودي لمدة 30 عامًا
لتوثيق كل الأنواع في الأسر
حول العالم ، نحاول تصوير
كل حيوان على خلفية سوداء وبيضاء
القضاء على الانحرافات
والسماح لك بالنظر في أعينهم
ومعرفة أن هناك جمالًا رائعًا
وذكاءًا ويستحقون إنقاذهم
، فلديهم حق أساسي في الوجود في
رأيي كما نفعل
[موسيقى]
30 أو 40 بالمائة من البرمائيات يمكنهم
اذهب بعيدًا في الخمسين عامًا القادمة والكثير
من الحشرات تختفي بالفعل ، فنحن
بحاجة إلى تلك الحيوانات للبقاء على قيد الحياة واحدة من كل
ثلاث لدغات من الطعام الذي نأكله
تأتي من حشرة من الملقِّح ،
لذلك من المهم جدًا أن
انتبه جيدًا وبصفتي
مصورًا
لم أكن أعرف ماذا أفعل أيضًا ،
فقد قمنا بعمل صور شخصية في الاستوديو لحوالي
12500 نوع من الثدييات
والطيور والزواحف والبرمائيات والأسماك
واللافقاريات ، لذا فإن كل شيء من
النمل إلى الأفيال الهدف هو الحصول على
20 إلى 25000 في العالم في الأسر بينما
لا يزال هناك وقت لأن
العديد من هذه الحيوانات لم تعد موجودة
في البرية بعد الآن انقرضت
في البرية ، لذا فإن مجموعات التكاثر الوحيدة التي
توجد بها مخزون البذور في حدائق الحيوان
خارج حدود حدائق الحيوان هي  طريقة رائعة
للبقاء على اتصال بالطبيعة
في حديقة حيوانات لينكولن للأطفال ، لقد حصلنا على
بعض الحيوانات المثيرة للاهتمام ،
قمنا بعمل ذيل النيص قبل شد الذيل
وثعبان الكرة وحطام القصدير وثلاثة
أرماديلو النطاقات
ولكن لرؤية هذه الحيوانات في
الواقع حية ومزدهرة وننظر
إلى الكاميرا والتفكير
هذه مشكلة كبيرة ولا يتم إجراؤها في
كثير من الأحيان مع المخلوقات الأصغر ،
حيث لم يتم تصوير غالبية الحيوانات التي نلتقطها
جيدًا قبل
أن لا يكون لدى العديد منها  لقد تم
تصويره على قيد الحياة من أي وقت مضى ، وظيفتي هي أن أصبح
صوتًا لكل هذه الحيوانات ، الأشياء الصغيرة
التي تحافظ حقًا على تشغيل الكوكب ،
إنها حقًا على مسؤوليتنا الخاصة
إذا تجاهلناهم جميعًا الذين أتينا إلى هنا اليوم من
أجل الحيوانات ،
أجيب على المكالمة  لقد جاء الحفاظ على
البيئة بالطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكن من خلالها
التصوير الفوتوغرافي ،
لذا فإن قوس الصورة هو محاولتي اليائسة
الأخيرة لمحاولة
جذب الجمهور للانتباه فقط
إذا أزلنا الضغط عن بعض المواقع التي
ستعود الحيوانات إلى الوراء.
هذه النافذة قريبة
منا ، ليس لدينا مقدار غير محدود من
الوقت
يمكن حفظ معظم الأنواع التي أقوم بتصويرها ،
لكن يتعين علينا فعل
شيء حيال ذلك ، فقد سُئل كثيرًا
عن حيوانك المفضل
لتصويره وهو
التالي  التالي